au cours de son déplacement maghreb le
ministre de l'intérieur gérald darmanin
se rend en tunisie le 6 novembre juste
avant sa visite en algérie le président
a demandé au ministre de l'intérieur de
se rendre en tunisie la semaine
prochaine pour une rencontre avec son
homologue à l'ordre du jour une
discussion sur la lutte contre le
terrorisme
en réaction aux sinistres attentats
commis par un ressortissant tunisien le
29 octobre à nice le premier ministre
tunisien hichem mais chichi a exhorté
ses ministres à coopérer avec la france
pour faire toute la lumière sur cet
attentat
mais il devra s'accorder avec gérald
darmanin sur un point crucial la
reconduite à la frontière des
clandestins tunisiens en particulier
ceux qui sont soupçonnés d'intégrisme
une vingtaine de tunisiens radicaliser
en situation irrégulière se trouverait
actuellement sur le territoire français
de tels individus font l'objet d'une
obligation de quitter le territoire
français une occupé f pour qu'ils
puissent rentrer dans leur pays natal le
consulat tunisien doit leur délivrer des
laissez passer consulaires
pourquoi la tunisie refuse-t-elle
quasiment 50% des laissez passer
consulaires qui autorise expulsion
la réponse est dans le droit des
étrangers comme l'expliquent l'avocate
de victimes de terrorisme catherine jean
marc larre ressortissants tunisiens
à partir du moment où il n'a pas de
passeport il ne peut pas passer la
frontière ne pas franchir la frontière
et donc son départ est conditionnée par
le l'accord des autorités tunisiennes
d'établir un laissez passer ou un
passeport pour que celui ci puisse
franchir la frontière
on a les moyens qui vont être
développées par les étrangers en
situation irrégulière en france l'on
veut reconduire et il va y avoir les
moyens développés par le pays d'origine
qui meurent qui veut pas forcément
récupérer ces étrangers parce qu'ils ont
réalisé aujourd'hui on n'a pas de
réponse concrète de la part des
juridictions sur cette obligation que
pourrait avoir un état et en particulier
la france par exemple de récupérer ses
nationaux et de laisser entrer ne
délivrer un document pour laisser
rentrer sur le territoire
pourquoi la réponse de la tunisie est
elle cruciale parce que les flux
migratoires en provenance de ce pays ont
augmenté lors de la dernière année
d'août 2010 9 juillet 2020 41,6 pour
cent des migrants passant par l'italie
sont partis de tunisie selon l'institut
national des statistiques transalpin
mais quel accueil réservera la tunisie à
gérald darmanin par rapport à ces
questions de migration est de retour au
pays
les explications de kader abderrahim
politologue spécialiste du maghreb et de
l'islamisme du pôle du tunisien c'est
une demande qui va être difficile à
satisfaire parce que le pays est déjà
dans une situation économique très
compliqué et qu'il doit faire face
depuis de nombreuses années à une
déstabilisation terroristes cette
demande de la france est légitime mais
sa place la france en situation de porte
à faux puisque la france elle même pour
le moment refuse d'accueillir les
combattants français qui ont été dans
les rangs de déchets qui sont détenus
notamment dans le nord de l'irak ou de
la syrie dans les enclaves kurdes
ces derniers temps gérald darmanin a
durci le ton vis-à-vis des migrants
suspects et d'intégrisme religieux
il a demandé aux préfets de placer la
centaine d'étrangers en situation
irrégulière suspecté de radicalisation
dans les centres de rétention
administrative
parallèlement emmanuel macron a annoncé
ce 5 novembre de nouvelles mesures pour
lutter contre l'immigration clandestine
avec un doublement des effectifs chargés
de contrôler les frontières